you remember you remember during the
2020 election
you had
the hunter biden laptop story the new
york post broke this story there was
this hunter biden laptop that was
discovered it had a ton of compromising
material not just a bunch of stuff with
drugs and hookers and
potential
personal luring crimes like that
but a bunch of stuff about hunter
biden's dealings in china
a bunch of stuff about hunter biden's
shady dealings in ukraine
a bunch of stuff that
implicated
joe biden
in hunter's shady business dealings in
china and ukraine
and when you tried to post that article
on social media
you weren't allowed to twitter facebook
google all these places shut it down
when you tried to privately message your
friends with this article
you weren't allowed to why because the
official story coming out of our press
was this is dangerous
false
hacked
russian
disinformation
a bunch of questions from this let me
just start with this
how much does the source matter right so
you hear the story of this laptop we
don't know a lot we do know that the way
that this information is getting out is
through steve bannon and rudy giuliani
how much do the does the source matter
here
well source matters a lot and uh and the
timing matters a lot i think
and to me this is uh this classic
uh textbook uh soviet russian
tradecraft at work
uh the russians have analyzed the target
they understand that the president and
his enablers crave
uh
dirt on vice president biden whether
it's real or contrived that doesn't
matter to them
and so all of a sudden two two and a
half weeks before the election
this
laptop appears somehow
uh without any emails on it without any
metadata
uh it just it's all very curious do you
think stuff like that could just have
been planted in there and be completely
fake
i do
i think the uh the emails could be
could be contrived
it's totally completely fake that's not
just some random talking head on cnn who
is giving that opinion well the the
anchor was she is just a random leftist
propagandist on cnn but the guy who was
giving his opinion
was the former director of national
intelligence for barack obama james
clapper this is a guy with a lot of
credibility or at least he's got
credible credentials he personally
doesn't have very much credibility at
all especially because he was totally
wrong oh yes this hunter biden laptop
classic
russian tradecraft disinformation
oh yeah not even just all the videos and
pictures we see with hunter biden
obviously in it doing lots of creepy
stuff with drugs and sex and young girls
no no not just that
all the emails are fake probably it's
all fake it's all totally fake news
and so it's really dangerous and we've
got to suppress that information
except it was all true the new york
times just admitted the new york times
admitted in a headline hunter biden paid
tax bill but broad federal investigation
continues that's not the real story here
the real story is the laptop which the
new york times in this article admits
was
legit
so you've got now
the the way that this was being
presented yesterday is new york times
confirms that the hunter biden laptop
was real
the new york times didn't confirm it
we already knew the hunter biden laptop
was real that was already confirmed the
new york times did not do any
investigative journalism to show that
the the laptop was real
the new york times just admitted it
and it's good that's a that's a moral
victory for us isn't it
that that the new york times except they
admitted it after it didn't matter oh
whoopsy daisy we got it wrong and
censored all of you and suppressed your
information and rigged the election oops
guess we got it wrong okay moving on to
the next one
it's propaganda that's how propaganda
works
okay it's not just our enemies overseas
that use this kind of propaganda and
censorship we do it too we do it to our
own citizens right now go to
naturallyitsclean.com
michael when you are picking a cleaning
product i know i've had this thought
before i always think it's a big debate
between do you want something that's
super effective that's going to clean up
the mess
or do you want something that's not
going to kill your kids or pets right do
you get the thing that's full of all the
harsh chemicals
but it's going to be it's going to work
really well or do you get the thing
that's made out of like bubble gums and
unicorn tears but it's not going to
actually clean
you don't need to
make that decision anymore you can get
the best of both worlds with naturally
it's clean a hospital grade cleaning
product that will not leave harmful
chemicals on all of your surfaces
naturally it's clean is a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals what's the secret the powerful
plant-based enzymes nature's solution to
cleaning when i'm talking powerful i
mean i mean
real real
hospital level enzyme cleaning power
naturally it's clean has safer chemistry
that just works right now you get 15
percent off when you head on over to
naturalxcleaning.com go get the daily
wire essentials kit stocked with four
great products it's naturalizedclean.com
michael
use promo code michael uh that is uh
incredible cleaning products the best
you're ever gonna use fifteen percent
off go to natural it's clean dot com
slash michael promo code michael
[Music]